Là, c'est tous les mégots qu'on a ramassés.
Franchement, à vue d'œil,
il y en a bien 2000 ou 3000 facile quoi.
Tout ça, ça représente beaucoup de suremballage
alors qu'il existe des alternatives assez simples
pour pouvoir s'en passer assez facilement.
On a réduit sur la poubelle jaune,
tout ce qui est recyclable de 70 %,
notamment parce qu'on
vient faire nos courses en vrac.
Jeter quelque chose à la poubelle,
c'est pas anodin, ça a des conséquences.
La poubelle, c'est pas un trou noir
dans lequel les choses disparaissent.
Salut, c'est Axel de "Et tout le monde s'en fout"
et aujourd'hui, on va vous parler des déchets,
de ce qu'il faudrait faire
et surtout de ce qu'il faut arrêter de faire.
Parce qu'il y a plein de trucs qu'il faut arrêter de faire.
Voilà.
Pourquoi on s'est levés un dimanche
à 8 heures du mat' déjà ?
Pour faire ce qui s'appelle une Cleanwalk.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Eh bien, c'est un ramassage
de déchets avec des citoyens.
Et puis, on ramasse tous les déchets
qu'on trouve sur notre chemin.
Là, on le fait dans notre ville mais on peut le faire
dans nos forêts, dans nos plages, etc.
L'idée est à la fois de nettoyer
concrètement notre ville
mais aussi de prendre conscience
de l'impact de notre consommation,
de la pollution de nos emballages
et de la pollution au sens large du terme.
C'est important de le faire en ville
parce que, en ville, tu te rends compte que
le peu de zones naturelles qu'on a en ville
sont les endroits les plus pollués.
Comme si c'était la poubelle, quoi !
Il faut se rendre compte que jeter
un papier par terre, c'est débile.
Mais jeter un papier ou jeter quelque chose à la poubelle,
c'est pas anodin, ça a des conséquences.
La poubelle, c'est pas un trou noir
dans lequel les choses disparaissent.
C'est pas : une fois qu'on le jette,
on n'en est plus responsable.
Le déchet, on en est responsable
jusqu'à ce qu'il disparaisse
et en général, le plastique,
ça met 1000 ans à disparaître.
Un mec s'est dit :
je pollue mais je fais ça joli, un peu artistique
et voilà...
Ça doit faire un moment
qu'il est là ce gobelet en plus.
Là, c'est que des sodas,
des bouteilles en plastique, etc.
Les bouteilles en plastique, arrêtons !
Cette bouteille en plastique
va mettre entre 100 et 1000 ans
selon le plastique à se détériorer dans la nature.
C'est une matière qui va être
recyclée plusieurs fois,
3-4 fois, grand maximum.
Évidemment comme c'est fait à base de pétrole
et d'autres produits chimiques,
ça va évidemment polluer son environnement.
Juste là, c'est un enfer !
- La touillette, c'est de quel type ?
La touillette, c'est beaucoup trop petit.
Normalement, ça, c'est du plastique
donc ça peut se recycler.
Mais comme c'est trop petit,
ça passe à travers les machines de tri...
- Ça finit dans l'océan quoi...
Direct. Mais alors cash, quoi.
Sans attendre, ça finit dans l'océan.
80 % des déchets qui se trouvent dans l'océan
viennent de nos rues.
Ils viennent de la terre.
L'océan, on lui doit une respiration sur deux.
Aujourd'hui, nos océans sont
en train d'étouffer par notre pollution,
par le dérèglement climatique qui en est lié.
On pense toujours que ça vient d'ailleurs
mais au niveau européen, même au niveau français,
la mer Méditerranée est
une des mers les plus polluées
et c'est de notre responsabilité.
Allez-y !
Pardon, excusez-nous !
On nettoie la planète !
À quel moment tu vois ça,
c'est-à-dire un truc qui est quand même ...
- De manière assez naturelle.
Tu te dis :
c'est un beau cendar !
Alors ça, ça te nique 500 litres d'eau.
C'est quand même terrible...
Ça, c'est du plastique.
- Ah ouais ?
- Oui, il y a une partie de plastique là-dedans.
Mixé avec plein d'autres trucs
parfaitement dégueulasses !
Le mégot de cigarette pollue
500 litres d'eau à lui tout seul.
Là-dedans, il y a des milliers de substances chimiques.
et il y en a plus d'une quarantaine qui sont dangereuses.
Il faut savoir qu'il y a du plastique là-dedans,
le filtre, c'est du plastique.
On en jette 40 milliards par an en France.
Vous savez pas quoi faire de votre dimanche ?
Venez ramasser des mégots avec nous !
Au lieu de passer le dimanche en famille.
C'est quand même mieux, non ?
C'est quand même plus sympa !
On va faire une petite photo.
De voir des gens comme ça qui se motivent
et de voir qu'il y a des gens qui sont là
et qui sont prêts à se bouger avec le sourire,
bien sûr que c'est rassurant pour la suite.
Là, c'est tous les mégots qu'on a ramassés.
Franchement, à vue d'œil,
il y en a bien 2000 ou 3000 facile quoi.
- Et on a fait quoi là ?
- On a fait une avenue, là !
On a fait une avenue dans une ville d'un pays.
Voilà !
Là, on a toutes les bouteilles en plastique.
Là, on a tous les papiers, tout ce qui est
les pailles, les petits plastiques, les paquets de cigarettes.
On est content, on a nettoyé notre ville,
on a fait une bonne action
et on l'a pas fait juste pour se déculpabiliser
ou se racheter une conscience,
on l'a fait parce qu'on avait envie de le faire.
Ça nous semblait important.
- C'est pas contre les déchets,
c'est juste pour que ce soit propre.
- C'est super, concluons là-dessus.
Moi, je trouve ça génial.
J'adore ce qu'il dit ce garçon.
Salut, je suis Maël,
président de la Maison du zéro déchet.
Venez, je vais vous faire visiter.
Venez avec moi, on va faire
ensemble une autopsie de poubelle.
En moyenne, ce sont 570 kilos
qui sont jetés par an et par habitant en France.
Seulement 35 à 40 % sont recyclés.
Ici, on a une poubelle type.
On va voir ensemble justement
de quoi elle est composée
et comment on peut éviter tous ces déchets.
Là ce qu'on voit,
c'est que dans cette poubelle, la majorité des déchets
est composée de plastique.
Cette bouteille plastique par exemple,
si on a la chance qu'elle soit
jetée dans la bonne benne,
elle va effectivement être recyclée
mais le plastique n'est pas recyclable à l'infini
contrairement au verre.
Il va falloir toujours rajouter de la matière
pour pouvoir produire du nouveau plastique.
Dans cette poubelle, on a beaucoup de contenants :
pour le jambon, pour les biscuits, pour les pâtes.
On a aussi beaucoup de sacs plastique.
Tout ça, ça représente beaucoup de suremballage,
alors qu'il existe des alternatives assez simples
pour éviter de produire tous ces déchets.
À la Maison du zéro déchet,
on vous en propose un certain nombre.
Je vais vous les montrer.
Par exemple, pour les bouteilles en plastique,
on a les traditionnelles gourdes,
dont il faut se réemparer.
Le cellophane et l'aluminium,
ce sont aussi des choses qu'on retrouve
beaucoup dans nos poubelles malheureusement
et qui ne sont pas très bonnes pour l'environnement.
L'alternative, ce sont ces emballages
réutilisables à la cire d'abeille,
que vous pouvez mettre sur vos contenants
ou emballer vos sandwichs avec.
Il suffit juste de les laver avec de l'eau froide.
Dans la salle de bains, on trouve aussi pas mal de déchets.
Ici, on vend quelques alternatives durables.
Vous avez des savons pour le corps
mais aussi des shampoings.
Tous ces produits, vous pouvez effectivement les acheter
mais vous pouvez aussi les fabriquer vous-même.
Ici, à la Maison du zéro déchet,
on vous accompagne avec des ateliers
pour fabriquer votre propre déo
ou votre propre shampoing.
Aussi pour fabriquer vos propres produits d'entretien,
mais aussi des ateliers couture
ou des ateliers pour apprendre à réparer
votre petit électroménager.
Bonjour, je m'appelle Marina.
Je me suis engagée dans une démarche
zéro déchet depuis environ un an.
Je vais vous emmener faire les courses avec moi
parce que c'est notamment en modifiant
ma façon de faire les courses
que j'ai réussi à réduire les déchets de 50 %.
Suivez-moi !
Du coup, je viens avec mes contenants
faire les courses.
J'ai fait peser mes contenants
à la caisse juste avant
donc j'ai une étiquette
qui indique que
mon contenant fait 222 grammes.
Je remplis ma boîte
avec le sucre qui est en vrac.
Pour ce qui nous concerne,
au sein de notre famille,
on a réduit sur la poubelle jaune,
tout ce qui est recyclable de 70 %.
Notamment parce qu'on
vient faire nos courses en vrac.
Je m'étais dit :
si on va dans un magasin bio
avec du vrac, ça va être plus cher.
En réalité, non.
Pour des produits comparables
avec ce que j'avais l'habitude d'acheter
dans un supermarché assez répandu en France,
le prix n'est pas plus élevé.
Quand on regarde sur les réseaux sociaux,
il y a des gens qui font du zéro déchet
mais à un point très, très poussé.
Moi, je fais ce que je peux,
avec mes moyens humains, temporels,
parce que je travaille, mon mari travaille,
on a des enfants.
Pour autant, c'est possible.
Maman !
- Coucou !
Ça, c'est plutôt le type de produits ou d'aliments
qu'on pouvait avoir l'habitude d'utiliser
avant d'être entrés dans la démarche zéro déchet.
Tout ça, on n'a plus trop l'habitude
d'en avoir à la maison.
Du coup, ce qu'on fait, comme
on fait nos courses en vrac,
je réutilise des contenants que j'avais déjà.
J'ai réutilisé des boîtes d'une marque
de boisson chocolatée
pour mettre tous nos produits.
Ça, c'est les pâtes en vrac
et ça, c'est les pâtes achetées qui sont emballées.
Maintenant, j'achète mon huile d'olive,
mon huile de tournesol, le vinaigre,
la sauce soja, en vrac.
Il suffit d'y aller avec la bouteille
et on remplit le contenant.
Exit les bouteilles en plastique.
Ça, quand je rentre des courses,
il faut que je le mette à la poubelle.
Là, je n'ai rien à jeter à la poubelle.
Je rentre des courses et je mets
directement dans mon placard
donc je gagne aussi du temps là-dessus.
L'avantage, quand même, c'est de réfléchir
à ses propres comportements
et surtout, de rayonner autour de soi
et de montrer que c'est possible.
C'est peut-être ça le message :
si vous avez des amis qui ont envie
de s'y mettre, ils s'y mettront,
peut-être pas mais ils feront
autre chose pour réduire les déchets.
Peut-être qu'ils pourront influencer de manière
plus importante les décisions politiques,
mais je pense que ça peut faire
un effet boule de neige.